olá a todos pessoal daqui quem fala é o
dar que seja muito bem vindo já mais de
um vídeo e eu estou aqui no ct e também
os dois que é um jogo que você espere
muito mesmo mas que não estou aqui
sozinho do que com o meu amigo dela foi
ouvido no cu meu show eu fiquei sempre e
agora eu tô eu já vi nenhuma troca de
ações do estádio é o estado seja o nosso
hoje mas 2008 fukushima foi essa e por
mim já que eu sou muito dinheiro aqui
outra duas aqui meu painel fotográfico
já apanhei 4 tarde falcão gosta de mim
naquela tarde só quem já perdeu a graça
que a companhia também espera por um
táxi vão buscar o oita o bicho transmil
boy
eu acho que vou morrer aqui dar à espera
de salvar o gol salvador só agora um
adverso ou seja eu contra o quanto antes
vai ser o bicho feio e você um
sobrevivente vamos lá ver como é que
isto vai correr não eu tenho que apanhar
o que 10 é isso tese a embora eu já cá
canta
o estudo
no mais o meu é porque júpiter e netuno
da ginetta já a festa do vinho
ai vai richarlyson já tocou agogô e time
to do espaço mil
tá né tá né o boy está à procura da mãe
que estava ligado aqui do tipo no meio
do nada
vim aqui à volta boi não vinha nem tarde
nada encontraram uma torta total estava
no meio do nada era ea agora já topei
tipo muro de pedra
o jazz e nectarina não tô mais pistas
uma tarde muito com isso
hoje minha meta é estar no time está na
austrália eu nunca fui só quer me levar
que foi só quebrantar que olha para trás
do pt
o último é de 800 ruivo não é que as
casas não saiba o reitor
até quem é é feito porque desaparece meu
eu passei outro lado meu fã trave que
vai agora voltar a ter direito a 32
o fogo está no gol
caro amigo seu conhecido como falta
então faltam zinha só falta vocês
as crianças não digo eu não acho que eu
estou dizendo para que a tarde não é tão
tarde meu ritmo é quem manda llanto
nenhum foi o look mais cinzento toque na
cara amigo
não é só quem não consegue matar está
focado seu chinelo não é e nunca eu tô
cansado e não conseguiu e deixou incerta
tarefas de maneira limpa não quero aqui
é de calma
assim mas agora vai sair